okay next question David why do you
think so many billionaires are trying to
go to space is it for exploration is it
for plunder is it that the earth is so
screwed that they want to leave I
believe that there's a couple factors at
play you here but you know Richard
Branson wants to go to outer space and
Jeff Bezos and Elon Musk all these guys
they want to go to outer space is it
because they want to make money from
outer space well maybe for some but I
think that that's too simplistic a
notion I think that for a lot of these
billionaires and I read an article about
this somewhere and I don't remember
exactly where very good article for a
lot of these billionaires outer space is
just another thing that you can just
sort of like buy and sell and develop
and use in the way that everything on
our planet is sort of available to them
for the taking right when you have the
amount of money that someone like Jeff
Bezos has nothing is with beyond your
reach right so the idea of do it would
be cool to have an island or it would be
cool to have a house on Mars it's almost
like it becomes the same thing it's just
something that if you have enough money
you can get it's like you already have
the yacht you already have the 10 100
million-dollar houses yeah what's next
out there you've bought everything up on
the planet got to go outside of our own
planet then and as far as the business
thing to the extent that there's a
business interest in outer space for
some of these billionaires and obviously
there is it's not I believe for their
personal enrichment because these guys
are all already incredibly rich I think
it's more for the prestige it's more the
idea of they did it they brought
humanity to space they established some
kind of outpost and created the next
frontier Jeff Bezos you were telling me
now his net worth is like 130 billion or
something like procced a hundred billion
only left November yeah in the past you
know less than six months it's gone up
36 billion dollars that's crazy even if
he could double that by making some
hugely successful space development
business or something it's not for the
money at this point for business I think
it's for the associated prestige that he
perceives would come with it maybe it's
a little bit philanthropic too it's just
a little bit of setting to me
it seems like their priorities are
somewhat out of whack I think you want
to take ten twenty billion dollars and
spend it on space I hear you you can do
that it's a nice little hobby yeah but
we could solve homelessness in the
entire country for the cost of twenty
billion dollars and yet they don't even
float that as an idea right I do that's
the one area where I start - and who are
we to say exactly what the spending
priorities of any billionaire would be
who knows what we would do if we were
actually in their shoes it's hard to
even conceive about having that amount
of money but we know of very specific
problems on our planet that we can solve
if we throw X number of dollars at them
and then the one that's less clear
exactly how many dollars we need to
solve but is increasingly urgent is of
course climate change and these three
individuals that we have pictured
Richard Branson Jeff Bezos and Elon Musk
they've all expressed concern obviously
for the environment but I'm not the guy
to tell them how to spend their money
but it would be nice to see them maybe
throw more money at that problem in some
way and help fix the planet that we have
this is like the nuclear option for
mitigating climate change though yeah go
somewhere else I mean head to Mars if
the planet here we can't live and and
that might be another point of view
which we've heard from some billionaires
which is the future of humanity on earth
has a time limit and whether it's a
couple billion years as the Sun will
eventually expand is it a couple billion
or ten billion now I don't remember four
we have some time we've got some time
yeah but in any case eventually the Sun
will engulf and envelop the earth so it
is not an indefinite home for Humanity